bonsoir relatifs suisse ce soir avec
crise notre fils devait pas trouvé de
baby sitter voulu emmener avec vous si
gill a toujours besoin d'un baby sitter
c'est vrai mais maintenant il en a une
et puis il a un tout petit baby sitter
grand comme ça qu'à cinq mois ce qui est
extraordinaire d'ailleurs vous me faites
penser c'est que chris vous a annoncé
qu'il était perd donc le jour de la mort
de votre père à vous donc de son grand
père comme si la vie finalement
continuer inexorablement cet instrument
site et je trouvais que c'était une
bonne idée est sage et gtl court
complètement alors vous êtes ici parce
que vous avez un cd live et un dvd
olympia 2005 véronique sanson et puis un
livre qui paraît chez plon qui s'appelle
la douceur du danger d entretien avec
didier varrault suite au documentaire
sur sur france 3 mais absolument pas ce
qu'on avait finalement tourné pendant 15
heures ce qui est beaucoup
et puis on a
passez juste deux heures huit sur l'a3
et il restait beaucoup de choses dit
beaucoup de réactions suite à ce
documentaire sur vous beaucoup de gens
qui finalement vous en dit vous avez
bien fait de parler de vos problèmes
avec l'alcool etc
je pense que quand on vous pose la
question il faut il faut répondre
honnêtement et sincèrement
sinon ça sert à rien d'occulté les
choses de celles et de ceux les autres
cultes et à soi-même et de les occulter
aux autres parce que les autres savaient
bien tout le monde me regardait de dinde
un maire d'asnières de deux heures oui
et on dise ah ben oui la pauvre héros ça
ça va pas du tout il ya plein de gens
qui sont
alcoolique et qu'ils savent pas un bien
sûr ici ils ne savent pas ils se rendent
pas compte
b bien et quand on s'en aperçoit on se
dit comme toi tu t'en ai aperçu
et on m'a invité à dîner chez moi et on
servait du verre tout le monde et pas à
moi et j'ai dit mais quoi alors
et puis la grèce a dit voilà il a dit à
ma famille qui étaient toutes là je je
ne comprends pas comment vous n'avez pas
vu et vous vous êtes pas aperçu de sa
souffrance et de sa misérabiliste et
disons parce que moi je me croyais
invisible et je croyais que personne ne
voyait que que ça se voyait pas et tout
grâce à chris donc vous en êtes sortis
c'est lui qui vous a sauvé la vie parce
qu'il a dit ça fait des années et des
années que maman est dans cet état
il a dit à votre famille vous fermez les
yeux vous voyez bien qu'elle boit oui
parce que c'est pas marrant pour un
parent d'avoir une fille acle alcoolique
alors on ferme les yeux on ferme les
yeux ça le truc et c'est ça le truc
c'est que on ne veut pas on veut pas le
savoir
alors maintenant il ya un truc que je
voulais vous dire aussi c'est que c'est
vrai que je parle de l'alcool dans ce
livre et que j'en ai beaucoup parlé dans
le portrait mais il faut aussi dire que
je suis une musicienne
voilà je suis une musicienne je fais des
tournées en minable que je trouve quoi
manger
je suis une musicienne
voilà je suis musicienne et et ça
m'énerve de ne parler que d'alcool quoi
en ce moment c
non
et que de l'eau une chanson et hérite de
mettre à la ce soir oui c'est cela notre
ami le fera mine et à ses rivières
nantais voit la juge je veux faire une
rectification
le seul truc que je veux dire c'est
qu'on doit pas toucher ni à la torah ni
à la bible ni au coran cd livres saints
tu les touches pas ça appartient aux
juifs ça appartient aux arabes
ça appartient aux chrétiens tu n'y
touche pas ça me touche shanice on va
pas effacer la soirée monsieur moi je
suis chrétien je suis catholique mais si
quelqu'un a envie de dire du mal de
jésus-christ ou des évangiles je le
laisse libre de le faire c'est la
démocratie ce
aujourd'hui véronique vous avez peur de
rechuter ou non moi j'ai choisi de vivre
une nouvelle vie
alors évidemment quelques fois
évidemment c'est tentant
parce que vous savez c'est révoltant
c'est révoltant de ne pas être comme les
autres de pas pouvoir boire un p'tit
coup comme les autres comme les autres
et là on trouve une injustice totale
mais la route est très longue et je sais
que dans dans quand je vais aux
alcooliques anonymes il ya des gens qui
qui ont arrêté depuis 22 ans et qui vous
raconte des trucs absolument mais mes
torts dans on a déjà demandé un
autographe aux alcooliques anonymes ou
bien alors en tous les cas on vous
souhaite de ne jamais retourner dans ce
piège mortel pour nous est que l'alcool
dans le lit vous parlez aussi de vos
parents on apprend que c'était de grands
résistants vraiment des gens qui ont
donné leur vie quoi pour repos la france
pour la liberté c'est très bien dans les
niches elle bergé
vous avez fait tellement souffrir en
quittant pour le père de de crise pour
stephen stills
un jour michel berger vous emmène à
l'olympia pour voir crosby still nash et
vous avez une espèce de coup de foudre
vous partez acheter des cigarettes mais
vous c'est vrai quoi d'habitude quand on
raconte ça on déjoue parti acheter des
cigarettes bon vous c'est vrai vous êtes
vraiment partie des revenus non c'est
qu'elle marque
[Musique]
vous dites que c'est un assassinat
ça a failli en être un ç'a failli en
être un mais vous savez je regrette rien
et puis j'avais je vais envie de de
changer de vie de changer de vie voilà
tout simplement et de et d'apprendre
autre chose et d'apprendre autre chose
autrement
alors stéphane style c'était c'était
vraiment un déjanté notoire à l'époque
votre père et ça vous inquiétez pas ça
ça vous attirer ceux ce côté dangereux
qu'il avait mais au début je savais pas
qu'ils étaient dangereux et je ne savais
pas dans quoi je m'aventurais d'aider le
jour du mariage ce avait envie de vous
de vous casser votre soeur violaine vous
dit viens on passe par la fenêtre
il est ordinaire son book et là vous
dites je pars pas parce qu'elle est ou
il ya les beatles eux qui sont invités
donc c'est un peu dur de ce car sinon
résister enfin c'était un peu par
politesse quoi et c'est vrai qu'il y
avait là
ma famille la famille de steve et ces
familles qui me qui m'a terrifié et je
me suis dit si je me marie pas ça la
fout mal quand même
mais je suis très content d'avoir fait
parce que sinon enfin la voilà en tous
les cas ça a été très compliqué c'est
une vraie plongée dans dans l'alcool
dans les mémoires mais très doucement
très doucement mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font
crise quand vous avez lu le livre j'ai
été surpris par ce que raconte véronique
le livre je n'ai pas encore lu je suis
arrivé je suis parti direct en tournée
donc tu m'as pas de montrer un bel élan
mais parce que le passage où elle te
déglingue
il ya tout ça il ya des moments il ya
des moments très violent quand même un
jour et vous met un coup de tête sans
père 18 points de suture il vous met un
coup de couteau dans le dos en fait
quand même des moments très vous le
saviez ça oui ouais moi je me savais
mais mais mais
ils ont été tellement vraiment j'étais
tellement petit quand ils se sont depuis
séparés que j'ai j'ai pas les souvenirs
de salomon à raconter quoi vous avez été
l'enjeu d'une bataille terrible
finalement bodmer obtenu votre votre
garde mais sa vie est pris ah oui à quel
prix faisait même failli le tuer son
père un moment vous dites dans le
bouquin j'ai eu envie de le tuer et puis
surtout j'ai demandé combien ça coûte et
de nature à gages non mais moi je
rigolais porte ce n'est pas cher mais
vous avez des séquelles de tout c'est
toutes ces guerres familiale
oui il ya eu un non non ça va en avoir
la 2 3 mais non les séquelles dont ça se
passe
voilà il ya n'est pas faire ton père
autrement salman rushdie est bien c'est
qu'on perd il va il va comment votre
père va comment votre père il va très
bien il a il a sorti un album
un album solo donc le premier depuis 15
ans et ça se passe bien il y passait en
tournée il ya pas longtemps ici avec
crosby zen hec puis ça va bien ici il
s'en sort bien il est si c'est quelqu'un
qui est très très passionnée de la vie
et je crois que bon il est on a tous un
peu vu à quel point et voilà un des fois
quand ça quand ça comme ça passe ou ça
casse kw à 2 face à kas un drôle de
vigan
non
géant
m
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est
noah
tous les ans
non
eric samson
les membranes en bas
nec tu dis moi aussi un autre nom
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
hino lardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu